hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we're
all aware of movie ripoff sir
whatever a big hit comes out there's
always an underground ripoff with a
similar title to make people think it's
somehow connected to the original if not
believing is the original itself for Tim
you got babe and then you got Doherty oh
you nasty ripoff of a movie you how dare
you try to take the good wholesome
decency that this milk ran and you try
to catch it on oh you're a despicable
movie where do you came out first okay
let's do it
oh you nasty movie nasty nasty babe how
dare you try to rip off Gordy yes this
is one of those strange instants --iz
where the rip-off may have come out
before the original if that even makes
sense it's about a pig on a farm
separated from his family and somehow
becomes world faiths yeah name one other
movie to actually manage to do that okay
okay so the formula has been done to
death but this is the movie that almost
got people to Nazi bait because they
thought it was the same thing Hey
apparently kiss liked it as you can see
one reviewer quoted as saying kids will
squeal fur Gordy come on let's not waste
any time it's no chewing the fat this is
dirty so it starts out with an old
narrator telling the story about a
little pig on the farm all the
similarities are gonna be your friend
nestled in the heartland of America
there's a place called meadow brook farm
they rape smokers brand jelly better
than anyone else in the world and on
this farm there lived that happy pig
family
yeah that's a rooster yes okay if even
the rooster is late on the line
cockadoodledoo then we are seriously
screwed okay so some big bad rednecks
come in to take the father without
consulting the farmer by the way in fact
you never even see the guy who owns this
farm and the rooster goes to inform one
of the little pigs named Gordon there
you are what's going on rich what just
me I'm quite Gordon your dad's in danger
we're taking him away
daddy Oh looks like someone gave gum to
the farm animals and to say do you want
to make a movie about it so after the
rooster tells boardy about his father
which is odd considering how there's six
other family members what makes Gordie
so special 40 stops I'm bi and tries to
talk to him get outta here
it might take you with me where are we
taking you up north same place they took
my father no we're sacrificing me to the
Oscar god of mire
promise me Gordie promise me you'll take
care of mom and the kids
remember 40 ain't care of the family so
I guess it's back home to look after the
family like you said right she's my
mother
I'm sorry Gordy another truck drove up
while you were gone
took the whole family what you mean he
was in charge for two seconds and
already he fucked it up dude that's
pretty harsh
what other offspring catastrophes do you
think happened oh oh Gordy while you
were away your father's been kidnapped
Oh God well you were saving your father
the rest of your family got kidnapped
okay I guess I'll say Oh
Gertie while you were busy saving up the
farmer fell down the well
sheesh all right Oh while you were busy
saving that the Hindenburg disaster
happens hey I guess I forgot what you
were busy with the Hindenburg disaster
Osama bin Laden shit back to life turned
into a transformer is destroyed Chicago
with the darkest
well one problem at a time Gordy is off
to find where the other truck took his
family all he knows is that he has to
head north so that's where he goes
[Music]
comes across a bar that really puts the
square and square dancing where a
country band plays for the crowd with
the help of the lead singers daughter
[Music]
this must be Hannah Montana's less
successful cousin Wyoming Shlomi though
to be fair I'm not gonna be there it's
annoying and it sucks okay school she
goes outside and finds a pig in a
blanket and decides he probably doesn't
have a hole so she's gonna keep it I'm
gonna take care of you my momma that's
funny I could've sworn I heard you say
mama people can understand the animals
it take the time to listen no kidding
people can understand animals if they
just take the time to listen I didn't
know that so much today I wonder if that
works for other things like how about a
pan you think works for a pan let's find
out hey here's a pan let's see if it
says anything so the girl named Ginny
sue can sort of understand Gordy because
she took the time to listen yeah a
whopping five seconds of silence I'm
sure nobody else has ever done that with
an animal now what am I gonna call you
well breakfast comes to mind I know so
she calls the animal pinky and decides
he'll be a great companion to have
around because what a shock she has no
mother oh did I forget to mention this
was a Disney production you sick parent
hating Fox good night good night
[Music]
good night pinky
ciao did you say goodnight to your
vagina don't make me force the Bible on
something I find confusing so because
they forgot to shoot the scene where the
father finds out he suddenly knows that
the daughter has a patient but he
doesn't mind anything that can get her
to keep that constantly robotic
unnatural smile throughout this entire
movie is cool with them so they keep
Gordy and decide to drop by their next
gig it turns out at this party there's a
kid named hanky who also only has one
parent quite a small dramatically
contrived world but luckily his rich
grandfather is there to keep him company
why don't you ask your mother to dance
miss you like this go on ask her I'm
sorry she didn't hear you I'm sure she
would have danced with you she had
really not dancing with your mom bums
you out dude I think even Freud would be
like kid get some real problems so he
goes to a swimming pool where Ginny sue
comes by to keep him company we saw the
way that man treated you taking charge
of your mom he's our new boyfriend
oh by the way did I mention that he can
swim and yet he's hanging right off of a
diving board isn't that like a person
with vertigo trying to relax on top of
the Empire State Building and you'll
never believe where this leads
[Music]
where do the idiot panel
so in probably the most embarrassing way
to be saved by anything anywhere
the pink gets hanky a floating dock and
pushes him to safety
weirdest rescue ever baby pig spider pig
does whatever a spider pig does with no
one around to help the pig apparently
jumped into the swimming pool pushing an
inflatable pool toy swam to the boy and
saved his life
look at the reaction on his face that's
the words of this whole ridiculous
scenario sinking in you would have that
reaction too if you had this story
repeated back to you we've been told
that the young voice is going to be okay
he's expected to make a complete
recovery physically yes mentally No you
are bully me for the rest of your
childhood kid you better start saving up
for therapy bills because you ain't ever
gonna recover from this boat on the plus
side the pink becomes a hero and the
rich grandfather talks about making this
sudden celebrity the mascot for his
company but hankies mother and fiance
who i guess are the bad guys now
actually don't want the pig and instead
want her to be the mascot thank you
you promised to help me how can you even
ask me to compete with a pig you know
unless you're in a Muppet movie that
line should never have any contact
anywhere so thinkI decides to adopt the
pig from Jenny sue who I guess doesn't
want him anymore kind of weird and the
fiancee is told to do two tests for
marketing research one with the mother
and one with the pig listen carefully
you take care of the pig and I want you
to use this this is a wide angle lens I
find that you want to shoot anybody to
do as I tell you moment oh no a
wide-angle lens it's not like he can
just back off the camera to make Gordy
look normal it's a wide-angle lens
Oh
but it doesn't matter what he tells
hankie about the wide-angle lens
yeah he can understand him now too and
Hank he switches the lenses around and
because this is obviously the world's
worst director he never looks through
the lens to see how it's turning out and
because the fiance is also the world's
worst producer he never looks at the
footage and just sends it off to the
test audiences boy trusting world isn't
it
goodbye hero big
[Music]
what the hell was I just looking at boy
I don't even think David Lynch could
figure this edit out why is it holding
on em for so long why is there a
heavenly glow all around him it's at the
Virgin douchebag this is the most
awkward transition it's like if I woke
up one morning and said fuck go into you
breakfast now
so something you may notice it's kind of
odd about this movie is that there isn't
much of Gordy talking once in a while
he'll say something but it's mostly just
watching the human characters I guess
they thought the world of marketing
research was much more fascinating to
kids than a talking pig in keeping with
the spirit of friendly competition I've
invited Hankey and his little friend
Gordy to hear the results of course I
just hope they're not too disappointed
well way to talk to your future
son-in-law ol hero Pig outsold the
competition 100 to 1 but Jessica had to
win I'm sorry my dear let's take a look
at the results they must have confused a
wide-angle lens with a fucking funhouse
mirror
seriously nobody shit this I demand a
retest
sorry sipes the public is spoken we
found our new image ladies and gentlemen
good job everybody
we destroyed my daughter but found a pig
it's a good week
so Gordy becomes a big hit which of
course upsets the fiance as they listen
to the latest Rap Album that Gordy
starred in called pig power in the house
yes I am dead serious
[Music]
[Applause]
that was pig power in the house
everybody keep an eye out for it in your
nightmares hero pig label puts on one CD
and it goes platinum oh come on
50 cent is good but fucking pig power in
the house there's no comparison how do
you account for it he gives people hope
if a pig can make it anyone can't
touching words touching where it's done
sure are lyrics did peak power in the
house can I do that again no I was right
on the verge of taking over what do you
want us to do kidnap Gordy so he sends
your two classic dumb thugs to try and
get Gordy but the kid else smarts them
and gets on a bus Goris the thugs call
the boss and pretend like they got it
mission accomplished mr. Snipes all
locked up in the trunk of the limo what
do you mean oh you haven't snatched
hanky have you we had to sir he wouldn't
let go of the pig what sense does that
make
they don't have the pink or the kids so
why wouldn't he just lie and say no that
they got the paint but not the kid
you're just making your situation worse
why would you make that up it's like
saying yeah yeah we got the pig
oh by the way I also spoke with your
fiance they try to track down a hankie
in the pig though by following the bus
wherever it goes but luckily they
escaped because the thugs are distracted
by a cross-dressing madman with
pantyhose on his head robbing a thrift
store now I'm gonna repeat that because
it bears repeating a cross-dressing
madman with pantyhose on his head
red pantyhose mind you robbing a thrift
store you know I'm tired I'm so tired
not of the bad movie though granted it
is horrendous but a films like this that
focus on one thing when clearly they
should be focusing on another
is this guy's backstory was he down on
his luck was he a mental patient what
drove him to do this why is he dressed
up that way any of these questions is
far more interesting than knowing what's
gonna happen to this fucking talking big
and yet it's the fucking talking pig
that we're focusing on shame on your
movie so so giving back to the not
cross-dressing robber story pinky and
Gordie come across Ginny Sue and her dad
what a coincidence and they decide to
give him a left when they suddenly come
across some sad sad news so like most of
the really important stuff that happens
in this movie the death happens off
screen and makes news around the world
he was laid to rest in st. Louis at a
private family ceremony and it must be
why there's cameras covering the whole
thing under ordinary circumstances my
beloved daughter Jessica would inherit
my industrial empire however rather than
devote our energies to corporate
business Jessica has chosen a personal
career for that in mind Jessica will not
be next in line to inherit royce
industries so the daughter doesn't get
it and the grandson is too young to hone
it who's that gonna leave there for I
leave my entire fortune in the care of
that's right fucking pig gets the
fortune well half the fortune anyway I'm
sure he left one for to his pogo stick
and the other four to the color blue but
hey Oh Wales a will
so now Gordy the pig is rich you can't
make this stuff up except for the fact
that somebody has an extremely poor wee
hanky as his translator yes his
translator Gordy uses the money to play
the stock market get the company back on
top everything except looking for his
fucking family hell he even does TV
interviews tell us Cordy is the new
darling of Main Street and Wall Street
what are your views on the outlook for
the American economy now if you excuse
me my professional career as a
journalist is
so thorny makes an appearance at a giant
concert and brings up the fact that he's
looking for his family
if pig power in the house isn't playing
there I'm not interested but it's all
good even President Bill Clinton gives a
call to show his support this is the
president calling from the Oval Office
on behalf of the American people it
gives me great pleasure to unveil and
your honor
your very own postage stamp
[Applause]
turns out Gordy gets kidnapped as I
guess security around the world's most
valuable animal is pretty light but one
of the band members saves in it finds
out that the fiancee was behind the
whole thing what do you do it has
nothing to do with hankies inheritance
it's a Rabi mr. Snipes go play your
banjo goober hey those might be fighting
words you don't have to raise your voice
in front of the y'all keep out of this
you ain't gotta
[Music]
[Applause]
very nice very nice and now Conway
Twitty I can almost hear the stillness
as it is to the sound of your heart
beating OH
[Music]
so because the mother is suddenly a good
guy now
she helps discover where the family is
and they try to go and save them luckily
they're at a slaughterhouse that the
family just happens to own and the
father just happened to be shipped to
and the owner just happens to believe
that the little kid has the authority to
shut it down
I guess this happens to be the mother of
good timing so Ginny Sue's father and
hanky's mother get together just like
the fact I think they shared a minute of
screen time porty gets back to his
family and they all decide to live on
the farm that apparently still has no
farmer so I guess that makes it okay so
that was Gordie or as I like to call it
pig in the shitty to be fair the movie
doesn't seem to rip off babe too much no
more than any other story about a farm
pig who becomes famous I swear it should
be its own genre it's just a stupidly
told story that makes no sense the pig
doesn't talk much and when he does it
looks like he's having a heart attack we
never see him with his family so there's
no concern about finding them and a lot
of the scenes are just straight-up
awkward there is pretty much nothing on
this DVD worth looking at
unless holy shit pig power in the house
music video that can't be serious
they did not actually be a pig power in
the house music video
oh my god there's actually a big power
in the house music video that people put
money into people's spent money on a
pink power in the house music video
Jesus Jesus Jesus people there is
nothing more I can say that this epic
phenomenal absolute masterpiece can't
say for me so screw the movie but for
God's sakes fine Pig power by tag team
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and powers in
the house
[Applause]
[Music]
go play your banjo goober